okay so we wrote we're rolling the clock
forward we're getting to later in this
year and then what happens what happens
okay to two scenarios first one is Trump
versus Biden second one is Trump vs.
Bernie what happens when they actually
standoff against each other I don't
think that the Democratic Party will
allow Bernie to be the nominee how did
they sabotage that I don't know how they
would do it by they would change the
rules at the last minute there's a lot
of corporate power in the Democratic
Party and I'm sure with the Labour Party
too they they pretend their self or the
people corporate power is powerful you
know every country in all parties right
they will these corporate Bernie's no
joke when it comes to democratic
socialism and you know contempt for
corporations and corporate power in
America he means that he's been saying
this for decades I don't know what they
will do but they will do whatever it
takes because as we're seeing here
you're not you guys aren't privy to it
the media has now started jumping
against him in collusion with the
Democratic Party so what the press did
against Trump in 2015-16 they're going
to do against Bernie they're going to
start dropping things I am absolutely
certain they will never let him be the
nominee
let's but let's pretend that he does
somehow let's potentially if it's Trump
versus Biden it is going to be the it's
not often we get to see an old man
beaten and laughs like beat until his
teeth fall out it's going to be harmful
to watch he's not well I think he's a
decent guy I think he cares about people
I think he is a little bit senile he
forgot Obama's name he's forgetting how
to talk often he just recently said ll
Beach LGBT OBGYN like he was he said
this this is not a function of you know
it's it's but it's kind of sad because
the guy suffered through a lot he's had
family tragedies I wish him not I make
fun of the son but I don't think he's a
bad person and even this all of this
even if the eruption were all true it's
hardly bad by political standards
everyone does this kind of stuff so I do
feel bad for him number one so I think
Trump would wipe the floor with him with
Anders if you had to anti-establishment
figures which I don't think there's
historic precedent for in the states at
least not for like a good 80 years I
don't know what it would look like I
don't I I mean I think it would be I
think the big loser there would be media
and social media would really seize
power because both of these figures
Trump and Sanders are very very social
media driven and anti-establishment in
every kind of sense Hillary you know
this is this lovely woman who Sanders
endorsed and campaigned for just
recently said no one likes Bernie and
he's never gotten anything done very
gratuitously
well that gives him an opportunity
because that means he's not beholden to
you guys and he is in a position to be
like we tried it your way Hillary lost
to the worst person in history an
election she should have won we have
this jackass now we're trying it my way
and that's a very compelling message I
feel mmm so you think that if if there's
no roadblocks put in place that you
could actually see Bernie getting
through it's conceivable but III think
the this would be kind of the I can't
think of another election America's had
that would have been this kind of messy
other than like William Jennings Bryan
and McKinley in like 1896 like it would
be
oh no no 68 68 you had three parties you
had Richard Nixon you had George Wallace
the southern racist figure and then you
had Hubert Humphrey from the Democrats
and they were riding at the Democratic
convention and it was basically at close
to its high in the popular vote between
Nixon and Humphrey and Nixon was reviled
by the Democrats understandably it was a
very very very dark election this would
be I think somewhat similar it's like
two south ends of a magnet right yeah
you get that and it's just real
everything yeah yeah yeah it would be
really really horrific in a good way
I love the carnage
[Music]
you